If your honor has this unique ability to
really take you there.
And that's sort of a,
something I've been trying to do.
And,
and traditional still images and
documentary film and,
and,
and those mediums have have great power
to influence.
But I was always frustrated with the
inability to really take a first person
subjective experience and let someone
see it for themselves.
And vr can start to do that.
I can place people into worlds that they
may never otherwise see and experience
something firsthand in a way that is
very different than watching a film.
You recall it as a memory instead of I
saw a movie,
I actually was there in this experience.
And so those memories actually encode in
a,
um,
in a stronger way.
And I think that allows us to reflect
and process them in a,
in a,
in a more personal way.
Uh,
you have an emotional connection,
uh,
and you get as close to being in their
position as possible.
It's not completely a first person
perspective.
And there's some testing and research
around that where it could be actually
embody someone else that's a little bit
harder.
But right now we know we can bet least
be very close.
And when you are very close to someone
and you're seeing what they're
experiencing,
you start to internalize that we have
these mirror neurons that we can feel
what other people are feeling.
And that reflection that I think is
invoked from these powerful experiences
can start to foster empathy,
uh,
for the other.
And it can dissolve your own ego and
help you take the perspective of someone
else.
And I think this special ability of Vr
is really important for the,
the,
the urgent crises that we're facing.
Uh,
especially climate change,
which can be hard to dig into,
to really lean into because it seems so
big and abstract and um,
but when you are experiencing climate
change right in the places that,
uh,
it's,
it's happening,
you feel like it's,
it's here that you're getting this
glimpse into the future of a world of
extreme weather,
of,
of dried out desert conditions,
of refugees,
of pristine ecosystems collapsing and
being destroyed.
And so when you can actually experience
these events as if you were there,
you internalize them.
And I think that starts to lead to this
process of,
well,
am I participating in it?
Am I consuming fossil fuels that I don't
need to?
Can I divest from some of the industries
that are responsible for this crisis?
And so I think that reflection is really
important because it leads to,
or as necessary to lead to action in
one's own life.
And there's a whole threshold of
different actions one can take to engage
with,
uh,
this,
this incredible environmental problem
that we're facing.
And so,
you know,
this chain of events I think can be
triggered,
um,
through a singular,
powerful experience.
And so with this medium,
we can convey,
uh,
not just information.
We can convey emotional fidelity in a
way that we haven't been able to do,
um,
with,
with such clarity.
And so we can really feel what it's like
to be a mother in the deserts of
Somalia,
uh,
trying to find food for her children,
um,
and,
and having to flee to the outskirts of
cities into huge,
uh,
camps.
Um,
and,
and seeing that they're really just
trying to care for their families just
as we would do if we were there.
And so I think it has this ability to
help us,
um,
invoke the empathy that we all have and
cultivate the compassion and the action
that is needed to address so many of the
world's problems.